they say necessity is the mother of
invention and in Rome pharmacist Giulia
pepillo is being forced to do some
chemical DIY using alcohol to make
batches of hand sanitizer after supplies
ran out people are increasingly worried
about the spread of coronavirus and
demand for disinfectant and masks is
growing in a dramatic move the
government here has ordered the closure
of all schools and universities across
Italy until at least mid-morning people
to avoid mixing with large crowds that's
already having an impact on major
sporting events as football stadiums in
big cities were being disinfected it was
announced England's final Six Nations
rugby match against Italy scheduled for
next week has been postponed and the man
advising the Italian government on the
crisis says these are necessary
precautions it is romantic actually the
decision that we are advising our based
on evidence and actually on closing of
school there is a limited amount of
evidence that this measure are effective
anyhow to contain we still believe that
this is appropriate to do it now the
doors to this university and language
school complex may be open but the only
people inside are a handful of staff all
of the students have been told to stay
away and that's a situation replicated
right across the country close to nine
million school pupils are now at the
start of an unexpected break outside one
of Rome's main colleges we met Christina
V Dhoni whose daughter is a pupil there
she backed the nationwide closure but
believes the government left it too late
that's the right decision for everything
even for sports soccer no now I think
they should do it early January for sure
she works as a tour operator and says in
recent days thousands of people have
canceled visits ask at any hotel here
and they'll tell you bookings are down
so too are Danielle o mascaras takings
the street performer has noticed things
are quieter is he worried this
question not know change if you worry or
the world windy
I don't worry but plenty here are
worried not just about the virus but the
impact it may have on tourism and the
economy Michelle Clifford Sky News Rome